It’s pretty awesome no one can mess with
us STARTING quarterbacks anymore
Sure, Sure, Yeah, yeah, right
Out of the way, Von
It’s a quarterback’s game now
God, I hate those pretty boys
Brock, wait up
I just wanted to say I’m really proud of you
This is the commencement of
The Annual Gridiron Heights Purge
At the siren, any and all penalties
including roughing the passer
will be legal
IT FEELS GOOD TO BE BAD
IT’S LIKE THE NFL FOUR YEARS AGO
IN HERE!
I’m allowed during the purge!
Oooooh! The purge looks fun!
It’s dangerous out there!
They’re celebrating with hip thrusts!
Oh my God, he’s mimicking a weapon!
And he’s wearing fun cleats to play
and not just as a pregame warm-up!
This is anarchy
We need to get to Matt Ryan’s panic room
THE REAL PURGE IS MENTAL, OK?!
NO PURGE IS PURGIER THAN THE PURGE
YOU’RE GOING THROUGH UP HERE OK
BREAK
OK
Cool
Thanks for that
You must love the purge, Vontaze
What’s the purge?
Baker!
I got purged
Coach, no!!!
Save yourselves
SCRAMBLE!
Trick or treat!
Here’s a treat
an extra-long episode of Gridiron Heights!
Wow!
Yay!
Told ya this neighborhood rules
Checkdown to be safe
Checkdown to- OOF
I DON’T THINK I CAN KEEP
UP WITH YOUS ALL
Well, yeah
We’re almost there!
Well, I guess there’s still the wild card
The purge is my cheat day
Sorry I have to sack you
No, that’s OK!
Great sack!
Great job being sacked!
JJ, look
I’m having a good season!
I HATE CHARITY
THE MONEY IS ALL MINE NOW!
GOOD JOB!
NOW BRING ME MORE HEADS, BOYS
WHY ARE YOU DOING THIS TO US?!
Don’t you see all the good the purge does?
It lets the defense get out their aggressions
so during the season
we have record scoring
God bless the new National Football League
Let the ritual begin!
But- but
but I’m better than anything else you have!
I must cleanse myself
of a quarterback every year
AHHH!
MY CINDERELLA STORY IS OVER!
KHALIL, YOU WERE MY BEST FRIEND
I’m so sorry
THE NFC IS MINE
What do we do?!
LISTEN, SOMETIMES YOU’RE TIED TO THE CHAIR
AND SOMETIMES THE CHAIR-
YOU’RE NOT AS GOOD AT PUMP-UP
SPEECHES AS YOU THINK YOU ARE
WOW, WHAT A FUN, EASY PURGE!!!